ach du scheiße ist
[Musik]
freunde der sonne hier ist mal eure
chemikerin des vertrauens und ich würde
sagen es ist zeit für ein bisschen ruhe
für tee und ein paar wissenschaftliche
fakten das schnell anfangen denn ich bin
ein bisschen erkältet oder wurde ich von
milch vergiftet findet es heraus ich
habe mir drei frage ausgesucht die ich
wissenschaftlich beantworten möchte
nämlich erstens was ist mit überhaupt
genau
zweitens ist mit gift und drittens ist
online pr genie und ja auch diese frage
werde ich wissenschaftlich beantworten
nummer eins was ist mich eigentlich
muttermilch enthält alles was ein baby
so braucht wasser kohlenhydrate
beziehungsweise zucker proteine
mineralien vitamine antikörpern ohne
ihren babys den milchzucker also die
laktose noch problemlos abbauen können
verlieren die meisten menschen diese
fähigkeit sobald sie aufwachsen der
großteil der menschen ist dato sind
nämlich circa 65 prozent
zum beispiel sind das 90 prozent die
natur so nicht vertragen wir lesen kann
man also ganz gut mit milch vergiften
vor 10.000 jahren allerdings begann sich
in einigen bereichen der welt eine
bestimmte genmutation durchzusetzen
die ist den menschen erlaubt milch
zucker abzubauen so dass heutzutage ca
35 prozent milch trinken können ohne
davon bauchschmerzen zu bekommen
woher kommt die milch naja dass die
milch von der kuh kommt das
aber warum wir jetzt ausgerechnet die
mutter milch von kühen treten ist nicht
unbedingt direkt nachvollziehbar
vielleicht erinnert sich noch jemand
2011 sorgte eine londoner eisdiele für
einen skandal weil sie eine eissorte mit
muttermilch herausbrachte muttermilch
von einer fremden frau bat ich aber dass
wir uns morgens muttermilch eines
fremden tieres auf unser müsste schütten
daran haben wir uns inzwischen gewöhnt
kommt ja zum beispiel auch einen
ähnlichen fettgehalt wie menschen will
ich aber der hauptgrund ist dass kühe so
ertragreiche milch geber sind so dass
sich komisch etablierte und heute so
beliebtes deutschland konsumiert pro
jahr rund siebeneinhalb millionen tonnen
frischmilch erzeugnisse unternehmen
nachzukommen werden oft sogenannte turbo
kühe eingesetzt eine zucht rasse namens
holstein frisia bzw
friesen kurz auch hf für genannt während
im jahre 1955 eine kuh circa 4000 liter
milch pro jahr produziert liefert eine
hfu bis zu 15.000 liter früher und
folgendes vielen vielleicht auch nicht
bewusst in großbetrieben werden die kühe
quasi dauer schwanger gehalten damit sie
auch ganzjährlich milch produzieren die
kühe werden nach der entbindung relativ
schnell wieder neu künstlich besamt
damit sie eben jedes jahr kalben
entsprechend leben solche turbo kühe in
der regel nicht besonders lange nach ein
paar jahren treten oft berufskrankheiten
angeführt werden aussortiert und landen
dann beim schlachter so gibt es auch
ausnahmen
es gibt milchbauer die sich dem trend
entgegen setzen und trotzdem kunden
finden die dazu bereit sind für den
liter milch mehr als nur ein paar cent
zu zahlen
aber die meiste milch die bei uns auf
dem frühstückstisch landet kommt eben
nicht von den grünen allen so wie sie in
der werbung gezeigt wird sondern von
regelrecht gezüchteten milch maschine
okay frage nummer zwei ist milch gift
usa vorziehen wenn man denkt dass milch
trinken einfach nicht richtig sein kann
dass nicht nur das einzige tier das als
erwachsene auch weiterhin muttermilch
trinkt sondern er ist auch noch das
einzige tier das die muttermilch eines
anderen tieres trinkt sind so ist das
schon heute mensch macht viele sachen
die andere tiere nicht machen nur wenn
etwas seltsam ist hat das noch keine
medizinische aussagekraft was ihr ziel
sind wissenschaftliche farben und die
habe ich mir immer genauer angeschaut
erstens kalzium und knochen kalzium ist
wichtig von sektoren wachstum und milch
ist eine gute kalzium quält eigentliche
milch enthält circa 1200 milligramm
kalzium und die empfohlene tagesmenge
sind 1000 milligramm
es besteht ein wissenschaftlicher
konsens darüber dass milch für kinder
und jugendliche in der wachstums und
knochen aufbauphase einen
gesundheitlichen vorteil hat uneinig
sind sich wissenschaftler allerdings
wenn es um osteoporose geht aus den
büros eine altersbedingte krankheit bei
der knochen brüchig werden und hat immer
wieder dass milch osteoporose fördert
weil in ländern in denen viel weg
getrunken wird häufiger osteoporose
auftritt das ist aber nur eine
korrelation und keine kausalität ein
zusammenhang aber keine ursache sehr
wichtiger unterschied sagen wir in
deutschland leiden mehr menschen an
osteoporose als in wien
außerdem wird in deutschland viel mehr
milch getrunken als in wien
das kann theoretisch bedeuten dass milch
osteoporose verursacht muss es aber
das kann auch genauso zufall sein denn
zwischen deutschland und wieder gibt es
viele unterschiede nicht nur den
milchkonsum wieder auslöst die
gesundheit von knochen von vielen
verschiedenen faktoren abhängig vor
allem von genetischen faktoren aber auch
von körpergewicht von rauchen von
hormonen östrogen also es gibt keinen
grund zur sorge dass milch schlecht für
unsere knochen ist aber es gibt auch
genauso wenig wissenschaftliche hinweise
dafür dass milch gut für unsere knochen
ist wenn wir bereits erwachsen sind
zweitens milch und krebs milch enthält
zu geringen teil so genannte
wachstumsfaktoren wachstumsfaktoren
nennt man proteine die sind beteiligt
bei biologischen prozessen die mit
wachstum zu tun haben das kann ein war
das normale wachstum seien zum beispiel
in ländern wo viel milch konsumiert wird
sind die menschen auch größer wir können
weder sagen ob die milch wirklich eine
ursache dafür ist und noch weniger
können wir sagen ob es die
wachstumsfaktoren in der milch sind oder
irgendwelche andere bestandteile zum
beispiel das calcium wachstumsfaktoren
können aber auch zellwachstum
zellteilung fördern und damit im
schlimmsten fall auch das wachstum von
krebs zum beispiel gibt es einige
studien die korrelation zwischen
prostatakrebs und milchkonsum sehen
korrelationen sind wie gesagt nur
bedingt aussagekräftig aber bei
krebsverdacht sollte man mögliche
risikofaktoren durchaus ernst nehmen was
allerdings wiederum gegen den einfluss
von wachstumsfaktoren spricht ist die
tatsache dass kein zusammenhang mit
irgendeiner anderen krebsarten bisher
gefunden wurde
im gegenteil im fall von darmkrebs
hatten sogar eine positive korrelation
gefunden also milchkonsum zusammenhängt
mit verringertem krebsrisiko drittens
diabetes und herz-kreislauf-erkrankungen
auch hier gibt es keinen
wissenschaftlich fundierten grund zur
sorge allerdings sollte man sich über
ein paar andere zu
anhänge bewusst werden kritisch sind zum
beispiel fettreduzierte fettarme
milchprodukte wer zum beispiel gerne
fettarmer joghurt ist muss sich darüber
im klaren sein dass die fed reduzierung
oft mit mehr zuckerzusatz kompensiert
wird denn sonst würde das ja auch nicht
schmecken tier ins milch und akne milch
kann bei jugendlichen die talgproduktion
erhöhen die ja sowieso schon erhöht ist
was zur pickel und akne führen kann auch
hier sind bisher nur zusammenhänge so
korrelation und keine direkten
pauschalität nachgewiesen aber man kann
einmal durch milch verzicht einen
selbsttest machen und schauen was es
einbringt denn eines klar eine gesunde
ernährung ist sicherlich auch möglich
ohne milch kalzium protein und auch
vitamin quellen gibt es viele andere nur
als gift würde ich mich jetzt nicht
bezeichnet weil natürlich auch die dosis
das gift macht ihr wisst schon alles ist
giftig einer gewissen dosis ist milch
allerdings ein gift für den planeten
da fällt mir direkt das etikett ab dazu
muss ich mal ein extra video machen oder
am besten direkt eine ganze reihe ich
selbst bin keine veganerin auch keine
vegetarierin leider vielleicht schaffe
ich das irgendwann mal ich unterstütze
alle vegetarier veganer und in dieser
hinsicht unterstützt sich damit auch
ohne weil ich weiß dass alles andere
einfach nicht nachhaltig ist aber bevor
ich jetzt hier ein fass aufmachen dass
ich an dieser stelle gar nicht
angemessen angehen kann kommen wir doch
lieber zur dritten frage nämlich ist
ohne ein pr genie muss mich ist gift
video war sicherlich höchst effektiv
darin eine diskussion auszulösen aber
nicht die beste methode um eine
konstruktive diskussion zu schaffen es
gibt ein gut untersuchtes
psychologisches phänomen
konfirmation bis jeder leidet darunter
der eine mehr der andere weniger aber
niemand ist wirklich frei davon conti
menschen beißt jetzt endlich dass ich an
meiner eigenen meinung festhalten egal
was kommt außerdem ist er schränkt gut
untersucht wenn wir uns einmal einen
eindruck gebildet haben dann lassen wir
die nicht los auch wenn wir wissen dass
dieser eindruck oder diese meinung
falsch ist ich habe dazu auch schon ein
zwei videos gemacht verlinkt ich euch
jedenfalls war es deswegen ziemlich
ungeschickt so geschickt dass ohne im
video sowas sagt wie wenn ihr mindestens
täglich milch noch nicht produkt erst
dann macht ihr euch kranke keine riesen
verschwörungstheorie die wehren
systematischen krank gemacht mit denen
die lebensmittel möchte ich wäre es ihre
bevölkerung krank wird kann möchte in
zukunft gesunde menschen in ihrem land
haben bewusst provozieren wollte und
dass milch für den einzeln vielleicht
doch nicht ganz so kritisch ist dass
veganismus aber trotzdem der richtige
weg ist es gibt unzählige weitere
studien über die gesundheitlichen aspekt
von milch allerdings kommen beim body of
evidence zum ergebnis dass zur jetzigen
standpunkt mehr studien für ein
milchkonsum vor allem im kindesalter
sprechen als dagegen wenn jetzt gar
nicht wirklich klar bewiesen dass das
mich ungesund ist beziehungsweise krank
macht warum habe ich dann die zugegeben
provokante aussage getroffen dass milch
gift sei es ist zwar wie bereits erwähnt
nicht eindeutig belegt dass milch
ganzheitlich schädlich für den einzelnen
menschen ist aber milch ist gift für die
tiere die davon betroffen sind und
ausgebeutet werden und mit ist gift für
unseren planeten da der co2 ausstoß und
die grundwasser verseuchung durch die
vier haltung um ein vielfaches höher ist
als das von autos und flugzeugen
das problem ist nur jeder der sich nach
dem ersten video gedacht hat sind
verschwörungstheoretiker bullshit wird
eines guten argumenten im zweiten video
keinen glauben mehr schenken den
eindruck den er im ersten video
vermittelt hat
wird er jetzt im nachhinein kaum mehr
revidieren können und damit hat er
möglicherweise vor allem diejenigen
menschen verloren die am ehesten
erreichen wollte nämlich die vegan
kritiker deswegen finde ich es schade
dass die durchaus gute argumente die uni
jetzt in seinem zweiten video
angesprochen hat in dem ganzen
halligalli so ein bisschen untergehen
und dass der große sturm den hunger ja
noch eigener aussage bewusst provoziert
hat so ein bisschen um die falschen
argumente heraufbeschwört wurde aber ihr
seid freunde der sonne und damit freunde
des sachlichen austausch deswegen
schreibt mir doch in die kommentare was
ihr zur milchgeld denkt und schreibt ihr
auch gerne fragen und gedanken zum thema
veganismus denn ich würde tatsächlich
gerne mal einen längeren beitrag dazu
produzieren und eure fragen da auch
gerne mit einbeziehen wir sehen uns
nächsten donnerstag freunde der sonne
bleibt sicher
[Musik]